now on good day a pause in adoptions at
the animal foundation what's behind the
stoppage as the organization is still
operating over capacity and freshly
squeezed and while squeezing your wallet
while your morning glass of OJ could
soon cost you more at Donny Osmond week
continues here on good day this morning
we're talking to the story about his
expansive career we dive into the early
days when he got some interesting advice
from his brother Good Day Las Vegas
starts right now
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now and a good Tuesday morning to
you it is five o'clock thank you for
joining us here uh sending it to Sherry
Sherry I just saw that uh Christmas
trees are going to cost us about 20 more
this year yes
oh man although it doesn't feel anything
like the holidays it's hard to even
imagine that I know got to dig deeper to
Deck the Halls this year for sure and uh
been getting notices about getting my
flu shot too so I get text messages from
my Pharmacy so you know flu season right
around the corner you guys now that
we're into October so lots to think
about lots to remember but in the
meantime just enjoy our pretty easy
weather that we don't have to worry
about yesterday we were on the lookout
for thunderstorms and it was definitely
humid and it's still a little humid out
there 36 humidity dew points at 47 and
some patchy clouds left over from some
passing thunderstorms that were around
the valley yesterday 76 degrees sunrise
at 6 38. uh temperatures are still above
normal we should have morning lows this
time of October in the 60s eventually
we'll get there but the week looks like
it's going to stay a little above normal
83 back by mid-morning into the mid 80s
by noon and we should really have a lot
more sunshine today maybe some
increasing clouds over the mountains but
we're not watching the skies for
thunderstorms in the valley today low
90's for our Tuesday afternoon we should
start to dry out a little bit more let's
get to the roads on this Tuesday morning
at 502. say good morning to Nate and
check the drive I want to Sherry good
morning to you thanks for getting your
day started with us here on Good Day Las
Vegas freeway is in excellent shape in
terms of no crashes surface treats as
well you do have a little bit of sewing
on the North 15 at the northern 215
Beltway as well as the 215 at the 95 in
the Centennial Bowl both of those
ongoing ndot projects and speaking of
that you know you do have a lane take it
away again this morning this is on the
southbound side of the 15 from before
trop down towards about Russell Road
eventually it's going to get really
nasty through there as a ndot's going to
completely rebuild the Tropicana and the
15 interchange this morning the overhead
sign is letting you know that that right
lane is taken away there's just not
enough traffic there to have that be a
big deal however nearby at Russell Road
in Las Vegas Boulevard one of the news
stories we're going to be talking about
there's some police activity around uh
Russell Road and Las Vegas Boulevard the
only camera we have working in the area
appears to show some traffic is moving
on the boulevard but we'll keep you
posted as we learn more Heather all
right Nate and we are going to talk
about that here a couple breaking
stories from overnight metro police
investigating two different homicides
this morning and one is in that area
that's Las Vegas Boulevard near Russell
the other near Rancho in Washington and
we don't know much about either case at
this moment so we're working to gather
some more information and as soon as we
have details we'll bring those two right
here on air and of course online at
8newsnow.com
to Florida now this morning where the
sheer destruction of hurricane Ian is
still being assessed more bodies are
uncovered now in the rubble the death
toll topping at least 100 local
officials are working to provide food
water other Aid to all of those people
affected while criticism mounts over
evacuation orders here's Christian
benavidez with more
across parts of Florida people sifted
through the personal belongings that
made it through the destruction Ian left
behind we really don't want to leave be
because this is all we have left cars
lined up for bottled water as the
Hurricanes far-reaching impact stretches
into a second week
finally got water
but it's a yucky one in Tampa hundreds
of volunteers from a Disaster Response
Team cook and serve meals for those in
need we've seen the devastation and the
only way this happens where people can
make a difference is when we all work
together as the death toll Rises
providing Aid is a door-to-door effort
by rescue we have four ambulances here
and we have two rescues here deer and
hard hit Lee County the sheriff defended
the response amid mounting criticism
over the decision not to issue an
evacuation order until Tuesday a day
before hurricane Ian made landfall we
got that message out at the right time
now whether people listen to it we can't
force people out of their homes but we
can continuously say look mandatory
evacuation
rebuilding after Ian one of the worst
storms to ever hit the U.S is expected
to cost billions of dollars tomorrow
President Biden and the first lady will
visit Florida to see the devastation
first hand Cristian benavidas CBS News
Fort Myers Beach Florida
just under half a million Florida homes
and businesses are still without power
more than 1600 people have been rescued
Statewide those rescue missions however
they continue especially to the barrier
islands in the southwest part of the
state those were cut off from the
mainland due to crippling storm surge
some local help though is on the way and
on the ground in Florida aiding in the
search and Recovery efforts this is Mike
Porter and Dexter one of 50 K-9 teams
assigned to FEMA Porter is a member of
Nevada Task Force One it consists of
local firefighters and other agencies
here at home Porter currently works as a
firefighter at the Nevada National
Security Site and Dexter and him and got
to Florida yesterday morning so we wish
them the best
in August a man's body was found in a
trunk an apparent murder victim now
Metro Police say they've caught the man
accused Metro Police say 37-year-old
Tony Dan was arrested last Thursday in
San Diego he's accused of killing Amir
[ __ ] whose body was found August 19th on
Tropicana near Valley View stuffed into
a white BMW Carr County coroner says he
died from a gunshot wound to the Head
[ __ ] was reported missing out of Arizona
in June Dan will be sent back to Las
Vegas to face murder charges
the 8 news now investigators uncovering
how prison staff really learned about
The Escape of a convicted murderer a
confidential Source tipped off officers
that's according to a newly obtained
memo while the department originally
said a press release they said officers
learned of Porfirio Duarte herrera's
Escape during account he's now being
held in Ely State Prison it's a maximum
security facility if you'd like to read
more about what the investigators
uncovered go to our website 8newsnow.com
the animal foundation announcing a pause
right now on all adoptions transfers and
fosters until further notice in a
statement on Twitter the foundation said
16 dogs at their shelter are dealing
with a respiratory illness those dogs
are on antibiotics organization says the
decision comes from advice from their
Veterinary team and an abundance of
caution on the shelter right now has
been operating at or over capacity for
several months the foundation did face a
contagious outbreak back in 2007 and in
that case sadly more than a thousand
animals had to be euthanized that
outbreak led to sweeping changes which
eventually helped the animal foundation
work toward its goal of becoming a
no-kill shelter just a couple years ago
Nate
all right your NV Energy bill is going
to be going up the company says a rate
hike is needed because natural gas has
gotten more expensive so how can home
and Business customers cut down on their
energy expenses we'll stick around we've
got some tips on how you can save coming
up in our next half hour Sherry yeah
that started happening back in the
summer well Goodwill will will be
hosting a massive job fair on Wednesday
that will be held from 11 11 A.M to 2
p.m at the Boulevard Mall there will be
over 20 companies looking to fill
positions so if you're interested they
say come dressed for success as there
will be interviews and job offerings on
the spot so for a full list of companies
hiring in the valley just head over to
8newsnow.com and click on our job board
tab we put together a long list with
links on how to apply Heather all right
Siri one of my favorite days guys it is
National Taco day and this morning we're
talking all things taco is with
Limelight kitchen Candace Charles man
she always gets the good jobs she's out
there with their ghost kitchen a live
look at this women-owned operation
Candace not only is it national taco day
but it's Taco Tuesday so this is just
perfect
it's right on point Heather and you know
I always got you covered with the fun
stuff as well as making things easier
for yourself now there will be some
deals we're hearing about as well as
freebies throughout the city but why not
try to make tacos yourself for National
Taco day and it's Taco Tuesday I'm
joined by Frank Rizzo she's from
Limelight kitchen as well as Chef
Natalie on the ones and twos or I like
to say the grill and we're gonna go and
talk to you guys really about the simple
way to make tacos I know it's easy right
it should be simple but what is the key
to making the perfect Taco uh so the key
to making the perfect Taco is right now
Limelight kitchen is bringing a fresh
take to Mexican Cuisine we create all
our own sauces we use all the freshest
ingredients and just being creative and
making it so it's lots of fun and
everyone can enjoy it awesome awesome
okay so what is Chef Natalie cooking up
on this side it's all like you said
about being creative and unique when
making these tacos uh yeah so I mean
it's really cool because the Limelight
is trying to create you know good things
for vegan people good things for
um you know the people who eat meat you
know chicken beef we have really great
ingredients everything is completely
fresh our shrimp taco is one of my
ultimate favorite tacos oh I love shrimp
tacos too so good so um by creating like
our own sauces in our own Pico and
things like that I think it makes it so
it's a lot more fun and it's delicious
and it's a little bit fancier than your
average Taco I like that a little bit
fancier than you have a chocolate Okay
so this is cooking up now of course
we're going to give you a sneak peek of
it coming up and then later on in the
show I got you covered with the healthy
option sense for making a tackles and of
course you can find all the details
about the Limelight Kitchen on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live from
there goes Kitchen in Henderson I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now oh man okay
the ones and twos I'm learning a lot
from kids now her dad is actually a chef
so she knows what she's talking about I
still had nothing better than not fresh
glass of OJ to wake you up in the
morning right
heads up that breakfast staple could
cost you more soon and maybe not for the
reasons you might think we'll explain
that and we also are continuing our oh
did Donny Osmond this morning why his
brother thought they really needed to
kind of toughen up their image Sherry
boy
Donnie as a bad boy
can't wait all right here's your
accurate day planner for your Tuesday
some patchy clouds around this morning
temperatures in the 70s will be up near
80 degrees by 9 A.M mid 80's for noon
another warm day still holding on to
some summer like temperatures highs in
the low 90s we will start to dry out
we'll find out if these temperatures are
going to change at all in your eight day
forecast coming up after the break it's
5 12. we're live local
eight now right now
live
this is good day Las Vegas
now it is a name synonymous with Vegas
Donny Osmond and our Donnie week
continues here on 8 news now as we pay
tribute to the Las Vegas Entertainer
with this residency in full swing and
just extended he carved out a little
time to sit down with me and talk about
the early days
singing alongside his brothers when his
career launched at the tender age of
five Donny Osmond quickly Rose to fame
becoming a teen heartthrob there's one I
remember in London
we're doing a television show and we
went outside and somebody
told all the thousands of fans over on
the front they're in the back and they
come rushing in the back we're running
on the streets of life it was like A
Hard Day's Night right and my my brother
Alan he's in the league come on guys
they're gonna attack us and I'm smiling
having a great time and we we see this
little Chinese restaurant and we duck
into the restaurant and hide under the
table and I could see in the window
these hundreds and hundreds of girls
rushing by and I'm thinking this is
awesome but that bubble gum pop was
happening simultaneously as the Osmonds
were trying to find an edgier Groove so
Alan said we got to be tough we got to
show a hard side a tough side so they
added karate to their stage routine and
people laugh when I say yeah Chuck
Norris was my karate teacher from
breaking boards on stage to Breaking
records with hit songs and then
launching Donnie and Marie how does that
go I mean with 65 albums how do you I
can't remember what I ate for breakfast
the cool thing about working with Marie
or family in general at least my family
we all figured out early on and thanks
to my dad
we learned to get along that certainly
doesn't mean there weren't creative
differences there were times with
Marines we're not going to do that yes
we're gonna no one remember
and the curtain goes up I'm a little bit
country
it was so funny and after the show we
looked at each other said that was the
best show we've ever done but not
everything has turned out perfectly and
Donnie says that's okay my career has
been up and down and everywhere in
between and this point in my life I
appreciate as I look back the down times
his resiliency and ability to reinvent
himself he says comes from family my dad
had always had a saying anything worth
doing is worth doing well
and he certainly has stay tuned coming
up in our six o'clock hour you'll have
your chance to win four tickets and a
VIP experience to see Donny Osmond
caller number eight will win we're gonna
put that number up for you coming up in
the next hour
Shari's a little karate he goes a long
way apparently oh my gosh from not even
having all of his teeth in yet that
story covered everything to Bad Boy
karate and with his sister act on on
stage that was a great story it gave us
a great behind the scenes of his whole
career there wow love that all right we
uh we had some bad boy thunderstorms
mainly in Arizona yesterday and a few in
our local mountains but really nothing
in the valley we're still a little on
the humid side temperatures in the 70s
around the Las Vegas Valley this morning
we should be having morning temperatures
morning lows in the 60s so we're not
quite in the swing of fall yet we do
have 60s in Mesquite Indian Springs
Pahrump this morning Sandy Valley and
Searchlight 73 actually a little cooler
in Laughlin this morning and Kingman is
in the 50s 44 in Cedar City 30s in Ely
with 50 in Caliente Tonopah and Reno
right on the bubble of 50 as well even
Death Valley is down below 80 degrees so
we're trying to get cooler the there are
some showers down around the Gulf Coast
of Texas more rain through Arizona New
Mexico today we'll get a drier influence
from the west coast to push away the
monsoon showers and thunderstorms along
with that low pressure that's around the
four corners and believe it or not the
remnants of Ian still circling up into
New England pulling in more rain out of
the Atlantic we've still got
thunderstorms around New Mexico
especially but boy they were hammered in
central Arizona yesterday big dust
storms around Phoenix even a tornado
reported in Coconino County ripping
roofs off of homes look at all those
Fierce thunderstorms along interstates
40 and 17. so again we did have some
thunderstorms in the mountains yesterday
Mount Charleston getting a little bit of
rain we had some thunderstorms up in the
Sheep mountains but nothing really for
the valley just some clouds we'll look
for Sunshine start drying out as we get
through our Tuesday temperatures staying
above normal in the low 90s pretty much
for the work week and then the weekends
temperatures do slide a little looks
like we'll get a couple of days in the
80s and mornings back into the 60s
pretty much Where We Belong all right
let's see what's happening on the roads
all right we are right where we belong
in terms of traffic as you're getting
going here trying to get out the door
safely before 5 30. the good news no
crashes to report however you may run
into some road closures We are following
a couple of uh crime stories or maybe a
crime scene around Las Vegas Boulevard
and Russell Road off the 15 freeway no
working traffic cameras in there but a
traffic tipster called in to said hey I
had to work my way around there at Las
Vegas Boulevard and Russell then there
is another completely separate crime
scene this does not appear to be
blocking any streets around Rancho and
Washington we do have a camera there and
it looks like this is in the parking lot
of one of the shopping centers in the
area but just keep an eye out for that
one in the meantime we're watching all
the roads for you all morning long
Heather all right Nate appreciate that
could some sweet orange juice be souring
your walnuts while you might be soon
shelling out more for that refreshing
breakfast classic coming up
on eight news now
eight on your side with an advisory to
check the cheese in your fridge could be
part of a recall a michigan-based
company called Old Europe cheese we're
calling some Brie and some Camembert
that could be contaminated with listeria
sold under more than two dozen different
different brand names at grocery stores
like Trader Joe's and Whole Foods now
the company is issuing this voluntary
recall for the cheeses with Best Buy
dates through December 14th Heather oh
we got to toss that one all right and if
your morning routine includes a glass of
OJ don't be surprised at the entire
bottle will be costing you more very
soon orange juice and other produce
production in Florida is expected to be
significantly impacted by Hurricane and
as you might imagine experts say 79
percent of Florida's total Citrus in
five Florida counties four of which were
hit directly by the storm and now as a
result orange juice strawberries
watermelons cabbages also could soon
cost you quite a bit more Sherry that's
all that good summer fruit wow all right
it's 5 25 let's take a look at your
accurate eight to eight forecast for
your Tuesday few patchy clouds out there
this morning but those will be moving
out near 80 by 8 A.M mid 80's by noon
and low 90s for your Tuesday we're
hanging on to these extra warm
temperatures as we get through the week
but we will start to dry out a little
bit more for your Tuesday and the rest
of the week when will the temperatures
feel like fall that's the big question
everybody's asking we'll try to answer
that in your most accurate forecast
coming up at 5 30. we'll be back after
the break live local now Heather acell
ahead on good day as fall weather what
we hope starts to come soon right
doctors do have a warning about flu
season plus users beware more on a
recent payment app scam it's costing
people thousands of bucks so stay tuned
pay attention to that one it's a good
day Las Vegas live local now
they're only three days a week in Fall
it's the law
we should have about 120 Troopers work
in the valley 24 7. I think we're under
60. now on good day severe Staffing
shortages hitting our state police force
we're going to take a much closer look
at how these shortages are negatively
impacting our community and we have some
positive progress reports about that
teenager from Las Vegas who had an awful
reaction to the Johnson Johnson covet
vaccine
and let's talk about it oh my goodness
we are live from a local Taco Shop
Candace and she's got all the good gigs
she's talking tacos trying tacos telling
us how to make tacos she's got it all
and the deals Good Day Las Vegas starts
right now
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now 5 30 is the time we'll forget
about coffee it's tacos I'm gonna do my
best John langler nom nom nom nom nom
nom he does do that you're almost there
never mind John's a little more John um
yeah those tacos talk in my language
and drool worthy I know oh my God so she
said shrimp are her favorite do you have
a favorite because I don't discriminate
I will eat any Taco in front of me
ground beef shredded beef don't care
don't care eat it all chicken oh yeah
absolutely yeah chicken soft taco hard
taco yeah vegetarian yeah we covered
them all yet oh how about that Choco
Taco which doesn't actually exist
anymore but I always loved that the late
great Taco Time
oh my gosh you guys stop you're making
me so hungry uh check out this beautiful
shot of the High Roller right now look
at the colors pink and purple a little
blue thrown in there as well gorgeous as
we've got partly cloudy to mostly clear
skies out there a few clouds left over
from those passing thunderstorms
yesterday we had thunderstorms in the
mountains some up north over the Sheep
range that just kind of fizzled out
before they got to the valley but they
did send some kind of threatening clouds
over the valley at least the north end
of town temperatures in the 70s this
morning still have humidity over 35
percent and dew points in the 40s so
we're on the humid side especially for a
desert measures for sure 80 degrees by
mid morning and we're going to have a
lot of sunshine a few of those clouds
says which should be thinning out really
and mid 80's by noon a sunny noon hour
will warm up again right above normal
into those low 90s we should be having
afternoons in the upper 80s and Mornings
in the 60s so we're still above normal
and it looks like we're going to stay
that way for a while but the eight day
forecast does have some changes in it
and there are still some thunderstorms
in the desert expected today we'll find
out where those are expected and the
chances for those let's take a look at
the roads though if you're heading out
the door got to know what the drive is
like here's Nate yeah and even as we
speak there are more cars getting onto
the South 15 out of the spaghetti Bowl
the good news no crashes the lanes are
open you're tapping the brakes just a
little bit obviously it's going to get a
little bit heavier as we get into the 6
a.m hour but a heads up uh we're
following a couple of crime stories and
Heather's going to give you the details
but as far as traffic is concerned you
may see a bunch of police around Russell
Road and Las Vegas Boulevard there are
no working traffic cameras there but a
traffic tipster let us know that he had
to work his way into his work area
through there in Las Vegas Boulevard and
Russell then near the spaghetti Bowl but
not on the 95 really didn't appear to be
even at Rancho and Washington we do have
a traffic camera here this looks like
it's off in a parking lot but we'll keep
you posted Heather all right Nate and as
you just showed us that video here we
are following those breaking news
stories from overnight so the first that
took place investigating a homicide this
is Las Vegas Boulevard near Russell and
as Nate mentioned you can see it's going
to take a little bit more more work to
get to wherever you need to go because
they do have the roads closed off in
that area police also investigating a
second homicide and that's the one
they'd also pointed out that's at Rancho
in Washington appears like he's said to
be in a parking lot so not impacting
traffic but we're still trying to get
more information about both of these
homicides Metro on the scene
investigating as soon as we have more
information we'll bring those to you on
air and online
an update to a story that we did bring
you yesterday morning as breaking news
please say a fight over property led to
a man being stabbed and killed this is
near Eastern in Fremont late Sunday
night the investigation is ongoing and
they're asking anyone with information
to contact Metro or to call Crime
Stoppers you know as always you can
remain anonymous that number is on your
screen at 702-385-555
the Nevada State Police facing a serious
problem officials say short staffing is
causing an uptick in car crashes
impaired driving and fatalities on our
roads the Nevada police union
representative is telling us 112 members
have left in just 2022 alone 12 to 14
Troopers are needed just to make sure
that each shift is fully staffed this
past Saturday there were just four
Troopers for the day shift
if we were to lose another let's say 10
between the end of the year that really
we're broken at that point that they've
talked about limiting a graveyard shift
just because we don't have enough people
to fill those vacancies right now the
department is operating with less than
half of a full team and because of
smaller staffs and higher call volume
the trooper Union adds that they've
started prioritizing which incidents to
respond to
a man is in custody after authorities
say he's sold more than six thousand
dollars worth of drugs to an undercover
detective police say on number of
occasions Emmanuel Montez sold them
large quantities of Controlled
Substances a search warrant at his home
then led to the discovery of more than a
thousand grams of illegal
methamphetamines as well as two guns and
ammunition hamantas who were working on
getting a booking photo of is now facing
several federal charges
the man accused of stabbing his
ex-girlfriend to death was later
captured in San Diego he's now made his
first court appearance here in Las Vegas
25 year old Michael Ricks is facing an
open murder charge as well as burglary
and child abuse charges authorities say
he loved his infant daughter alone in
the home after he got into an argument
with 20 year old Michaela Adams Ricks is
expected back in court tomorrow for a
bail hearing
one person is dead following a
paragliding accident it happened in
Boulder City happened Sunday morning in
the desert on the south side of town the
Boulder City Fire Department says the
motorized paraglider was found in a dry
lake bed bystanders attempted
life-saving measures But ultimately that
person passed away
some good news here in Nevada teen
making great progress more than a year
after she had a very bad reaction to the
Johnson and Johnson covet vaccine Emma
berkey's Family Sharing us this video
take a look you could see her walking
her goal is to walk without having
anyone to help her she's had to endure
five surgeries including three brain
surgeries with feeding tubes and
breathing tubes so we are just so happy
to see her smiling and a great progress
report there
doctors warning this could be a nasty
flu season in fact they're urging all
Americans to get vaccinated this year
those over the age of 65 are advised to
get a special shot with Extra Protection
just to boost their immune response Nate
on your side at 5 37 on your Tuesday
morning got a scam alert for one of
those popular peer-to-peer payment
services this one specifically Zell or
some kids call it the zelly there's a
new report saying nearly 200 000 cases
from four different banks have customers
saying they were tricked into making a
payment to somebody or some business
those cases amounting to a loss of
around 213 million dollars the report
also finds the big banks that partly own
Zell have not been giving customers
their money back no comment from the
company that runs L ironically the
companies called early warning Services
Sherry oh I call it zelly my son calls
it Zell and says mom no it sells one or
the other okay
well have you noticed your NV Energy
bill going up a new rate hike is in
effect for customers and the company
says it's thanks to Rising costs of
natural gas which started back in the
summer with Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and hot summer weather well this has
caused many consumers to look for ways
to cut down on their energy expenses the
same applies for businesses a
sustainability consultant offers these
energy saving tips
definitely lighting is going to be one
of the easiest ways that people can save
money switching to LED from like
incandescent or fluorescent lighting is
a good start and also maybe having like
your equipment service because even
things such as like filters being dirty
can cause inefficiencies in your
equipment
those are all good tips and for more
energy saving tips from Envy energy you
can head over to our website
8newsnow.com Heather uh the gas that we
put into our cars unfortunately also on
the rise let's take a look at those
numbers the average price this morning
552 a gallon that's up a cent from
yesterday a week ago we were paying 40
cents less and by the way we're paying
about a buck 70 more than the national
average so it's uh it's not looking good
for us here in Las Vegas
silicon though on good day we're talking
about the death toll now from Hurricane
Ian unfortunately it's continuing to
rise we're going to look at a progress
report regarding the rescue efforts
because people are still being plucked
to safety and today National Taco day
we're live from a local Taco Shop
Limelight kitchen and we're whipping up
some tacos with Candace when we come
back oh those look yummy our Tuesday
looks pretty yummy too if you're still
enjoying the warm almost summer-like